I couldn't care less about the Pluto
nonsense not even a planet who cares I
am NOT a planetary scientist but I could
not help but get swept up in the
excitement it felt like such a worldwide
event you know it was all over social
media it was all over Twitter you could
follow the spacecraft long live on NASA
TV
it is funny astronomy makes the news in
a really disproportionate way to every
other science and so actually there's
always something exciting going on in
Australia but yeah I think you're right
that actually people have this sort of
fascination with planets or not planets
depending on your perspective when it
comes to Pluto and so actually yes when
you get to see a new world that no one's
ever seen before I guess that does
generate a degree of excitement that you
don't get from most astronomical
discoveries because it's advised
exciting ISM as a little block of ice in
my freezer it's just not it's not a
planet it's just a rock it's not
important what sites are going to learn
for Pluto nothing in my opinion so it's
just tibialis is just padding to the
Americans well was there an American
that discovered a discovered Pluto this
is what I as a child of the 1980s grew
up with the National Geographic picture
atlas of the universe and I must have
memorized most of this book this is in
my childhood the best image that we have
of it and the blob enos of this image is
what indicated to scientists that Pluto
had at least one moon do you think it's
a planet I don't care I really really
don't care I was actually so this was
voted on by the International
Astronomical Union a few years ago and I
was a member of the IU and I could have
- Lee gone along and cast my vote and
but it why why does it matter it really
doesn't matter very much
right I mean Pluto still Pluto it's
still the same object that it was what
you choose to call it in some fairly
arbitrary way is not science in any real
sense of the word it's just an arbitrary
definition of we'll decide this many of
these ones of planets and these ones
aren't so the moon is this little lump
on the side and if if there's any
mystery left to Pluto its how you
pronounce the name of that moon because
at the new horizon
press conference we heard about half a
different have a dozen different ways of
pronouncing it so I'm going to call it
Sharon because that seems to be one of
the standard ways but I'm sure people
will disagree with my pronunciation of
that if tomorrow someone came along and
said Andromeda is no longer in galaxy
all the other ones we're going to call
galaxies but Andromeda is going to have
some new classification
I can imagine you having your nose out
of joint because you're into galaxies I
would but the reason the only reason my
nose would be out of joint is because
actually there are good physical reasons
why Andromeda is like in 33 and various
other galaxies that there clearly is a
commonality between the brain in this
case it's just an arbitrary judgment
call this clearly there's some kind of
sliding scale between things that we
call planets and things that you'd call
Kuiper belt objects and Pluto is
somewhere in that sort of gray area
where you're going from one over two
over to the other but it's which which
side of that boundary you choose to name
it really is completely arbitrary it's a
riddle
gravity maybe four percent of Earth's
density less a nice mass about one-sixth
of our moon core unknown what is it it's
actually bad for science to get hung up
on this right because actually it gives
the impression that science is all about
really rather subjective judgments and
and arguing over over the names of
things Oh arguing over classifications
rather than actually understanding how
planet you know the science is about how
planets form and if you could show that
Pluto had formed in some fundamentally
different way from the other eight
planets in the solar system then then
I'd be very happy that really that you
should give it a different name at that
point but until we actually understand
the science at eye level what you choose
to name it really is pretty arbitrary
and arguing over the name rather than
arguing over how planets form is I think
sort of counterproductive to science but
I thought Pluto was different on the
other planets isn't the argument that
maybe Pluto was a captured object if we
if we understood that and knew that then
maybe I'd be happy to give it a
different name but you know if I look
through the solar system and so you know
if you can play a mercury and Jupiter
you know they're both planets and yet
that I would say that mercury and
Jupiter are more different than mercury
and Pluto if you just
pictures of them so why we've decided
mercury and Jupiter we'll call those
planets but Pluto which actually looks
quite like mercury isn't the planet
until you as I say until you can come up
with some science behind it to justify
why actually that really is a
fundamentally different type of object
then then just giving them different
names is rather misleading because it
says yes they are intrinsically
different objects before we really know
they are and as I say it sort of tracks
from the science which is the fun bit of
trying to figure out how the solar
system formed in the first place and
this evidence that was used against
Pluto which I believe is the clearing of
its orbit like it hasn't hoovered enough
stuff out at all but that's needs to be
what cost Pluto is planet status you
don't think that science it at some
level it is but Prasant you know you can
look elsewhere in the solar system and
you can say actually jupiter hasn't
really hoovered out its orbits because
that's all those Trojan asteroids which
kind of more or less share Jupiter's
orbit actually because you put all the
massive it's sort of anchored them there
so it looked like one of those examples
where there was a reverse engineering a
definition which allowed you to for
whatever reason decide to tow wasn't a
planet anymore I think what was going on
is they started finding these more
distant objects like areas and so on
further out and there was this worry
that suddenly we'd end up with the solar
system with 300 planets in it which
would just confuse everyone
and so they wanted some definition that
would allow them to cut off the solar
system more or less where it was and
unfortunately the definition they came
up with also cut Pluto off when you're
talking about particle physics you're
talking about the nitty-gritty of size
you know you're stripping everything
back and learning about this sort of the
core of things where things really come
from at the most sort of raw and naked
level I mean it's sort of like the
ultimate truth really this is this is
why particle physics is so beautiful why
it's so dominated by things like
symmetries and things that are so
elegant good perfectly well I said
historically okay we'll call the solar
system everything that was discovered
before 1950 you know and then Pluto
would have been a planet but you know
they chose not to do that and but it is
just a matter of definition that does
seem less scientific well yeah I guess
so but except it's it's sort of more
justifiable in the reaction well I guess
that's reverse engineered as well as
Nick just kind of get the answer you
wanted but yeah it's but it's all pretty
arbitrary I think the other thing that
we found out in the bigger picture is
the diversity of objects in our own
solar system and so this idea
there were nine classical planets well
that that's changed dramatically over
the years you know at the well at one
point we thought there were 16 planets
you know it just depends how you count
them gives this impression that science
is about stamp collecting again you know
how you choose to name things and all
that and the fact that it can change you
know that the Buddha used to be a planet
and now it isn't makes it just seem
science very arbitrary and that means
that when you translate that into other
fields like more contentious ones like
climate change and so on it gives it
gives this impression that actually
scientists are just making these
arbitrary judgments and actually any
judgment you choose to make is perfectly
valid just because well my arbitrary
judgment is at least as good as a
scientists arbitrary judgment whereas
actually you know real science isn't
about that sort of stamp collecting side
of things it's an important part of
science but we have to collect data we
have to categorize dojo and so on but if
you get so hung up on the categorization
that means that you're actually
shortchanging the science you're not
actually moving on to say to answer the
interesting questions like how did the
solar system form and gluto form in a
different way from the rest of the solar
system I think that of course it's
impressive that we can though we can we
have the technology to do things like
that and I just don't know
Pluto's where I would have gone weird
you are the Nile of Saturn we just added
hang around Saturn yeah they're just
doing well because people have an
emotional attachment to the planets they
learn them in June you know in infant
school they learn the names of the
planets and so actually people get very
upset when you suddenly say actually no
that one's not a planet anymore so I
think there is that sort of emotional
angle to it which there isn't in most
areas of science and that I don't think
that's helpful to science if scientists
are seem to be arguing about that it's
fine it's oh you know I'm happy to argue
about it over a pint of beer but it's
not it shouldn't be seen as a scientific
argument at that point you have a you
have a son I don't know if he's going to
become an astronomer or not I doubt it
very much
yeah what do you tell him about Pluto on
the planets pretty much what I just told
you actually that you know whether you
choose to call our planet or not doesn't
matter to Pluto Pluto still the same as
it was so it really doesn't matter what
you choose to call it
you're like son I want you to make your
own decision about the planet absolutely
yeah so the astronomers know how you
feel about Pluto and I don't know maybe
they feel to say about pentaquarks
because it's that's that Tony told me
this morning he thought this visit to
Pluto was incredibly boring and it's
just another rocky icy thing and it's
nowhere near as interesting as a lot of
other stuff going on in science why is
he wrong um look at look just look at
that image look at the surprises that
that image brought up you know this is a
this is a world that is changing
changeable it's got an atmosphere it has
snows it has surface features it's
hardly got any craters which means that
that surface is somehow refreshed yes
this is not something that I'm going to
be writing papers about but I cannot
look at that picture and and be amazed
I'm team solar system I'm team solar
system is turning out to be a much more
interesting place than having simply
nine planets that's so boring just
saying oh we've got nine planets we've
got a much more interesting solar system
than that Pluto plays an enigmatic role
in that whole system whether it's planet
or not I don't think makes a difference